the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we're now at story board 19 panel B in
the last lecture I mentioned that we're
going to be looking at several special
cases with regard to the metabolism of
fatty acids the first special case
concerns and metabolism of fatty acids
that can already contain double bond you
remember from last time that a double
bond with a trans configuration forms
naturally during beta oxidation in the
special case we're going to look at now
the double bond has a sis configuration
fatty acids with a syst double bond
typically come from membranes one of the
ways nature plasticizers our membranes
is to make them more fluid by putting in
sis double bonds that bend the fatty
acid molecule and reduce stacking
ultimately this reduction in stacking
results in a lowering of the overall
melting temperature of that part of the
membrane the example I'm going to uses
allele coenzyme a this fatty acid a CL
coenzyme a comes from oleic acid which
also has the short km notation 18:1
Delta 9 that is there is a double bond
nine carbons in from the carboxylate the
reaction I've shown in panel B goes
through three rounds of beta oxidation
resulting in a sis
Delta three inwe'll coenzyme a the
enzyme Olli Weil coenzyme a isomerase
will then remove the acidic hydrogen
from the two carbon repositioning the
double bond and then putting that double
bond into trans configuration which is
now amenable to further hydration and
beta oxidation
overall the isomerase has taken this
double bond and repositioned it to make
it a trans double bond that is now able
to undergo further oxidation by the
classical beta oxidation pathway let's
turn now to panel C of story board 19
second special case that I'd like to
deal with concerns the way that we
metabolize fatty acids that have an
uneven that is odd number of carbons in
them one example would be the C 15 fatty
acid Penta decanoic acid which we get
from milk fat in this case six rounds of
beta oxidation will release six acetyl
coenzyme a s but note that we're left
with a three carbon residue a carboxylic
acid called propionyl coenzyme a nature
doesn't like to throw anything away
it's going to take this three carbon
molecule propene ilk away that doesn't
easily integrate into any other
biochemical pathways nature is going to
add a carbon to it hence making it into
a four carbon molecule as we'll see that
four carbon molecule will integrate
seamlessly into the TCA cycle the
conversion of the three carbon compound
into a four carbon compound begins with
the enzyme propionyl coenzyme a
carboxylase in a few minutes we'll look
at these fine details of how this enzyme
works for now however what it does is
use the cofactor biotin in order to
introduce a carbon dioxide or co2 into
the two carbon or of the propionyl
coenzyme a the two carbon is the middle
carbon of the propia neill group this is
now a branched molecule that's called
methylmalonyl coenzyme a next the
molecule is subjected to a carbon chain
rearrangement that takes the branched
molecule and linearizes it to form
succinylcholine Sime a sectional
coenzyme a will then enter it directly
into the TCA cycle to allow its carbons
to be metabolized fully to co2 in
summary nature puts a co2 into the three
carbon propia neill co a forming a four
carbon branch structure then in an
amazing rearrangement that we'll look at
later the branch molecule is made linear
forming succinylcholine tur mediate so
the otherwise useless c3 molecule
propionyl coenzyme a is converted to
something of value lastly let's turn to
panel D I'm going to deal more with the
details of this reaction in a few
minutes but for now what I'd like to say
is that there are many sources
appropriate
not just from odd chain fatty acids in
the diet secondly the introduction of
succinate into the TCA cycle results in
an increase in the amount of carbon
going through the TCA cycle that is this
is truly an antibiotic reaction this is
an reaction that we can use to increase
the overall rate of carbon metabolism in
the TCA cycle we're now going to turn to
storyboard 20 let's look at panel a in
the last lecture on fatty acid
metabolism I talked about protein Eelco
a carboxylase which uses biotin to add a
co2 moiety to the middle carbon of
propionyl coenzyme a this lecture is a
chemical interlude in which we're going
to look at propane eel Co a carboxylase
and several other car box lasers that
are used in biochemistry one of these is
acetate co8 carboxylase this carboxylase
puts the co2 group onto acetyl co a to
make malonyl-coa
which is the precursor to fatty acids
during the fatty acid biosynthesis
reactions let's also look at panel B
we're also going to be looking at
pyruvate carboxylase which adds a
carbonyl group to the pyruvic acid
molecule in order to make oxaloacetate
this is one of the anaplerotic enzymes
that can increase the quantity of carbon
going through the TCA cycle that is it
facilitates and applause as' in the
biological system let's now look at
storyboard 21 panel a the carboxyl aces
all use carbon dioxide as their
carboxylated
reagent co2 itself is not very soluble
in water so cells use carbonic anhydrase
in order to hydrate it to form carbonic
acid the biotin carboxyl a subunit will
then phosphorylate the carbonic acid in
order to form a chemically reactive
intermediate known as carbonyl phosphate
or carboxy phosphate now carbon dioxide
by virtue of its structure that is a
carbon with two electronegative oxygens
pulling on it is pre activated for
nucleophilic attack and as I said a few
minutes ago co2 is just not present at
high enough concentration in the cell
for it to be able to add effectively to
nucleophiles a nucleophile such as the a
midnight region of biotin
would be an example so what the cell
does is use ATP to make carbonyl
phosphate which is a very water soluble
molecule it's a very efficient delivery
vehicle for carbon dioxide into the
active site of an enzyme now let's look
at panel B the biotin carboxylase
subunit of pyruvate carboxylase has a
biotin cofactor at the end of a 14
angstrom long swinging arm this subunit
of the enzyme breaks the bicarbonate
phosphate bond and releases carbon
dioxide in high concentration in the
active site biotin on the swinging arm
then attacks the high concentration of
carbon dioxide in order to become n
carboxy biotin as shown in this figure
the n carboxy biotin takes advantage of
its swinging arm to move away from the
active site at which it acquired the co2
and then move to a second site on the
enzyme at which the arm releases carbon
dioxide once again at high concentration
but this time co2 is released at high
concentration in the vicinity of the
substrate pyruvate pyruvate in order to
be a good nucleophile to acquire the co2
probably exists as shown in the figure
as the pyruvate enolate let me review
panel B at this point overall this
reaction has resulted in putting a
carboxylic acid residue on the 3 carbon
of pyruvate and this results in the
formation of oxaloacetate thus
activation of pyruvate carboxylase will
result in taking a molecule of pyruvate
and converting it to oxaloacetate this
anaplerotic reaction gives the ability
to increase the volume of carbon that's
cycling in the TCA cycle thus allowing
you to be able to increase their overall
rate of respiration and as I've said
several times in the past oxaloacetate
is present at rather limiting
concentrations within the mitochondrial
matrix so this is a very useful
biochemical reaction at this point let's
move on to storyboard 22 and look at
panel a let me loop back now and give
some bigger picture points with regard
to carboxylate chemistry pyruvate
carboxylase and the other enzymes of
this class have two active sites one of
them is the biotin
box'll age domain where a biotin moiety
covalently attached to the enzyme will
acquire co2 let's call this step one of
the reaction scheme once the blatant on
the swinging arm has been n carboxylated
as in step one the N carboxy biotin
moves to site 2 where the substrate is
the second site is the biotin
transferase domain in the example I just
used the substrate was pyruvate but it
just as easily could have been another
quote-unquote carboxylation substrate
for example propia Neel Co a in the case
of pyruvate as we just saw
it's the pyruvate enolate that becomes
carboxylated insight 2 in order to form
the final product oxaloacetate this
carboxylation of substrate is the second
and final step of the overall reaction
take a look at panel B now let me give
you a second example of carboxylase
chemistry in this case our substrate
will be asked to tell coenzyme a we're
going to use the same chemistry we
described a minute ago for pyruvate but
in this case it is another carboxylase
acetyl co a carboxylase that picks up
the co 2 residue at its carboxy
transferase domain in step 2 which
occurs in the carboxy transferase domain
the substrate esse teal'c away picks up
co 2 on its 2 carbon the one distal to
the coenzyme a group to form the 3
carbon product malonyl coenzyme a we'll
see later that the carbon dioxide that's
been added to acetyl co a to form
melanie Ocoee
is an excellent leaving group millennial
co a is the fundamental precursor to all
fatty acids through the fatty acid
biosynthesis pathway again we'll see the
details of this reaction scheme later
but keep in mind now that this is a
biotin requiring reaction just as the
one we just looked at with pyruvate
carboxylase let's look now at panel C my
last example of carboxylase chemistry
will be propia Neel coenzyme a
carboxylase i mentioned earlier that the
breakdown of odd chain number fatty
acids results in the formation of a
three carbon linear fatty acid called
propane Eelco a I also said that nature
doesn't want to waste any of the
carbons what she is going to do is add a
carbon dioxide or co2 to the central
carbon of the propia Neel group as well
as fatty acids with odd numbers of
carbons certain amino acids such as
isoleucine methionine and baleen and
threonine for example also break down to
form propia neoui so what I'm going to
do now is describe a fairly general
method of metabolism that involves
restructuring of the carbon chain
subsequent to the carboxyl age reaction
in this overall reaction a carboxylase
is going to carboxylate the middle
carbon of the propia neill group then
following the carboxylase reaction
there's going to be a skeletal
rearrangement to form succinylcholine
enter the TCA cycle as shown in the
reaction scheme propionyl coenzyme a
carboxylase carboxylates
pro pineal co a to form a very specific
stereo isomer s methyl malonyl coenzyme
a please note the position of the
carbonyl group that's highlighted in
blue this carboxylate in blue is
attached to a methylene carbon that has
an inverted triangle on top of it
epimer ization about the carbon with the
triangle results in the blue carboxylate
pointed down the way i've drawn it the
resulting epimer is our methyl malonyl
coenzyme a in the art methyl malonyl
coenzyme a molecule I put a little lasso
around the hydrogen atom at the
methylene moiety of the molecule I've
also lassoed an electron in some of the
atoms of the coenzyme a moiety a vitamin
b12 dependent enzyme called methyl
malonyl coenzyme a mutase which contains
an adenosylcobalamin functional group
will now act on this molecule in this
enzyme a cobalt residue is going to
enable the formation of an adenosyl
radical look at the book for the
detailed mechanism but for now it's
sufficient to say that this adenosyl
radical is going to facilitate the homo
lid excision of the bond between the
carbon and hydrogen of the our methyl
malonyl coenzyme a
that is you're going to get a free
radical formed at the carbon that has
the small blue o written over it that
molecule will lose its hydrogen atom
that hydrogen atom will migrate to the
carbon that has the small blue triangle
coordinate Li the carbon with the small
box that's part of the coenzyme a
carbonyl group will migrate to the
position originally occupied by the
hydrogen atom on the carbon with the
small o over it the skeletal
rearrangement is shown here in panel C
and it results in a linearization of the
original methylmalonyl coenzyme a if we
redraw it as in the box you'll see that
you form succinylcholine xym a sectional
coenzyme a will then feed directly into
the TCA cycle this is an antibiotic
reaction that is it will increase the
volume of carbon that's rotating in the
TCA cycle
overall in the way of review the three
carbon compound propia Neel coenzyme a
by way of the carboxylase reaction is
converted to a four carbon branched
molecule called s methylmalonyl coenzyme
a it's appears a ssin forms the our
methyl malonyl coenzyme a which is the
substrate for a third enzyme methyl
malonyl coenzyme a mutase a vitamin b-12
enzyme this enzyme catalyzes a free
radical mediated rearrangement of the
side chains specifically one hydrogen
and one coenzyme a functionality
switched positions this rearrangement
linearizes the molecule forming
ultimately succinylcholine xym a which
then flows into the TCA cycle